[Music]
[Applause]
these Jay Millis ESPN college basketball
analyst joining us on the program Jeff I
said the reason for this year's final
four is none an anomaly older players
nil hurting the bigger programs
three-point shot
or other
I'd say it would be more anomaly Dan
that even though there are some firsts
in this year's final four it's the first
time uh since 79 when they went to
seating that there's not a one two or
three seed in the final four
but at the same time we've got a four
two fives and a nine uh if you go back
to 2011 uh we had a uh a three uh four
uh nine and an 11. and so I mean the the
seed numbers were higher that year we
don't have a double digit C this year uh
Florida Atlantic won 30 some games in
the regular season they're ranked in the
top 25. uh UConn was ranked number one
at one point in the season uh in late
November
um it's not like this is some shocking
uh final four we just have some first
timers and we didn't have any knockout
punch great teams this year but we've
had years like that before San Diego
State the only Final 14 that was ranked
pre-season top 25 and they were 19th
and I know preseason rankings are always
difficult because you're not quite sure
team matures or player you know they
Mash or somebody gets heard whatever it
might be but uh still that's pretty
shocking
yes and no I mean San Diego State's not
allowed to lose so they're ranked they
got beat by Arizona when Arizona was a
top-ranked team all year long they got
beat by Arizona and Maui and then they
lose a couple of conference games
they've lost five games overall they're
not allowed to lose in the Mountain West
and so you don't get a lot of respect
from voters when you lose and UConn went
on a six-game slide which you know was
kind of hard to explain but you know in
November everybody thought they were the
best team yeah and uh and they go on
that slide and then they picked it back
up again and at the beginning of the
tournament you know when the bracket
came out that was the first thing I said
was like UConn I mean UConn's gonna
gonna win this thing and you know then I
thought about it longer and said well
maybe Arizona and then Arizona I was in
the first round but but that just went
to sort of the no knockout punch teams
you know we we had a bunch of good
really good teams but nobody was was
great was truly great but uh you know
and people will say that's what they
want you know they want that the little
guy to have a chance which it does every
year like there's nothing more fair than
the NCAA tournament everybody gets a
fair shot to get in all you have to do
is win your automatic bid which is
against your peers and it's done in
almost every conference I think it is
every conference now it's done by a
tournament and so the truth is everybody
is in the NCAA tournament all they have
to do is win their automatic bid and
they get in
um but but uh and then they take the the
next best teams after that and that's
where the argument comes in is what is
what does best teams mean after that is
there a philosophy a growing philosophy
of not focusing on the one and done
everybody wants a great player I mean we
only had one big time freshman Brandon
Miller with Alabama but
is that an anomaly that there wasn't
that impactful player the freshman
no I mean see what what I think is
happening is it we've always had older
players in the overwhelming majority of
teams because very few teams could get
one and done and certainly very few
could get enough of them to rely upon
them so Duke was doing it Kentucky
started doing it when John Calipari got
there in 2010 but then you'd see other
big programs North Carolina would take
you know one maybe two
and blend them in with older guys but
the you know then the narrative starts
if if a one and done team loses see you
can't win with freshmen well since 2010
uh two of the teams that have won the
most have been Duke in Kentucky and they
did it with largely with Freshmen the
transfer portal came in the NCAA put in
this transfer portal and there seems to
be a shift now that you're going to go
okay why not take an older guy with
experience for two years then take a
younger guy for two years
and and so you're seeing a little more
of that and a little less Reliance on
freshmen right now I don't know how it's
going to shake out you know John
Calipari I and and again I haven't
talked we may have talked about this
earlier I haven't talked to Cal about
this so I don't I don't know what he
thinks but from my seat it looked like
he was trying to get ahead of the
transfer portal started taking some
transfers and he's not as talented and
next year he's got a number one
recruiting class coming in I don't know
if it'll shift back or it'll be a
combination but a lot of coaches are
saying hey why not why not take the
older guys you know get experienced guys
and and uh and have them for a couple of
years and when they're older instead of
having for a couple years when they're
younger and you have to have to train
them and everything he's Jay billis ESPN
college basketball analyst when are we
going to see players go from high school
to the pros again
as soon as the MBA changes the
collective bargaining agreement and and
it's going to badly hurt college
basketball
um if you look back over the last
I think the one and done rule came in in
2007 something like that
um and and we've had like you have a
hard time convincing me or I think any
other reasonable basketball person that
the college game is better without Kevin
Durant and Kevin Love and Derrick Rose
and Brandon Miller you name it uh the
gay air Zion Williamson you know Zion
Williamson carried the sport for an
entire year and was the biggest deal in
the game and and if they just
immediately go to the NBA or we see more
of these guys go to overtime Elite or
the g-league ignite of course it's going
to hurt college basketball but it'll
still be it'll still be really good but
it won't be as compelling there's no way
can nil offset that if I'm you know 10th
15th best player could I get you know
this truckload of money for one year one
and done
yes I mean we're we're gonna see guys
stay longer I mean we're already seeing
it we're seeing guys come back that
otherwise would have gone and tried the
NBA maybe a second round pick or a late
first whatever that are coming back for
another year they're using their coveted
year fifth year whatever it is
um and you will see one and done is
never going to go away because you're
always going to have guys that will come
in to college they'll blow up and
they'll leave after a year so we're
never we're never gonna be done with one
and done it's always going to exist as
long as there's freedom in America
um but but you're going to lose the top
ranked prospects and over the course of
four years you lose Five Guys a year
that's first second third and fourth
team All-America and uh so it's
certainly going to hurt the hurt the
product overall and I'm not sure the
NCAA actually gets that there's still a
there's still this clutching of Pearls
by NCAA administrators that say if you
don't want to be Bill Bradley or Shane
Battier we don't want you at all and I
think that's very short-sighted not only
for the business but for the if you
really believe in education for the
benefit of young people to come even if
it's only for a year or two to establish
a relationship with an institution of
Higher Learning where they're actually
more likely to come back
Brandon Miller no showed in the
tournament how does that affect does
that affect uh his NBA stock in your
opinion I don't think so I mean he had
an injury he's dealing with a groin
injury uh so I don't I don't think
that's a big deal at all he established
a body of work where everybody knows
he's the real deal so I'm not I'm not
sure that's a big issue and uh and even
if somebody at number three said uh well
you know he didn't play well in the
tournament and they uh they said we're
going to take somebody else then he'd go
at number four
uh Hoosier Cinderella now
Florida Atlantic I mean they're they're
really good and they've been good all
year I mean the the problem in
evaluating a team like Florida Atlantic
is they won I can't remember how many
games they won during the regular season
whether it's 29 or 30. uh I think it's
31 uh because they're they're they have
a chance to win 37 if they win out uh so
31 regular season games but only six of
them were against the the top 100 and
you know they beat Florida they lost Ole
Miss by 13. but they're they're legit
they just play in a conference that
doesn't provide them with a lot of high
profile games but man they when they out
rebounded Kansas State 44-22 and they're
a pretty small team outside of their
Center who's 7-1 uh Vladimir golden uh
they they get their noses dirty man
those guys are good players and they're
tough and and they're athletic and they
can they can score so I don't put it
past them to get to the final
what would you say to somebody who has
picked the final four correctly
I would say they were either flipping a
coin or they had family members that
live in Boca Raton or San Diego
um I I I think it's I think what what is
it like zero zero zero zero point one
percent of all the brackets had the
final four right
um I I can't imagine uh having having
picked that on Sunday and felt good
about it well we have uh one of the
danette's wives picked uh all four got
all there you go yeah all four final
four and she breaks down a lot of tape
Seton is that right yeah a lot of tape
yeah yeah so found value in the uh in
the way they they run that screen for
the screener action yeah uh and how they
switch ball screen action that that
that's got I missed that I heard her
mumbling about catch and shoot the other
day wow she's really in it yeah yeah I
like it uh any rule changes do you think
are coming for college basketball in the
off season
I doubt it I mean they're I'm no longer
on the competition committee which has
made my life so much better and now I
can just watch the games without feeling
any responsibility for officiating
issues but there needs to be a change in
the charge block rule it's a it's a mess
and a joke and uh and we need to go to
quarters but we're not going to because
there's too much money in halves uh with
commercial inventory
um and I think the game needs to be we
need to address the uh the overt
physicality in the game but we're not
going to
um because all the checks are rolling in
and uh and it it requires too much for
the system to handle and the system's
not set up to to react to what is going
on in the game we're gonna have to wait
until there's another crisis like there
was 10 years ago do you think In Our
Lifetime we'll see dimensions of the
court or the height of the basket change
I don't think so I don't think there's
any any need for it and one the cost
would be enormous on all these different
levels
um but I don't see the need for that uh
what about NBA
well I I definitely don't see a need for
that I I think the game the game is fine
it does need the NBA has done the best
job the NBA and FIBA have done great
jobs of of changing as the players
change most of the Innovations come from
players and their ability to do
different things and you know the NBA I
think if College went to the NBA's rules
where uh they had a defensive three
seconds and uh and the charge the charge
rule was was backed up on a secondary
Defender to The Gather instead of when
the the offensive player leaves the
floor so as a secondary Defender as you
know you can slide underneath the guy
that's won a path to the basket and as
long as you get there by the time his
toe lifts off the ground you're
committed by the time your foot hits the
floor but not by the time you leave the
floor and uh and the NBA is a much
cleaner better game and it's more
entertaining it's higher scoring it's
fun like Reese Davis said this recently
said basketball is supposed to be an
offensive game with a defensive
component and most every game that we
covet
um they they the offense is featured and
the defense has to do something
extraordinary to stop the offense
whether it's football or or the NBA and
in college all we talk about is defense
and physicality and uh and it shouldn't
be that way like the game's way more
physical I'd love to play now because I
could just I could just bully uh better
players you know before you couldn't do
that and and people thought it was
physical back in the 80s it wasn't
physical like today it was just there
were there were no flagrant fouls so
when you fouled somebody you put them
into the wood and got your money's worth
now that's all cleaned up because of the
flagrant foul rule but but the general
contact in games is is uh is magnified
it's so much more than it used to be I
keep telling people the best shooter in
college basketball
plays at Iowa
Caitlyn Clark yes oh it's not close
she's she's the most exciting player in
in the game right now and has been for a
couple years and that 40-point triple
double she had yesterday and that that's
the thing like you know you watch the
women's games and they don't allow them
to grab and hold and Chuck Cutters and
Bully each other it's a it's a cleaner
better game and and look I love college
basketball but some of these games are
unwatchable and uh and I think we could
do a better job like the officials do a
really good job but it's their bosses
that don't do a good job and until
they're told that that they need to do
they need to call this and call it
consistently uh and it changes like some
of these officials will call a great
game when two teams don't play that
style of basketball but when you have
teams that do play this overtly physical
style they allow it and say well you
know it's the way they play no no you
don't you don't like cops on the side of
the road don't say well I can't give a
ticket for that because that's just the
way they drive no no oh like and the way
you stop people from speeding is you
give tickets out and they stop speeding
if you just uh if you just sit there
they're going to continue to speed it's
the same thing with officiating great to
talk to you thanks as always Jay always
Dan enjoyed it that's uh Jay billis
College Basketball analyst yeah he loves
Uconn and then all of a sudden he said
no I'm going to pick Arizona
and then we all scrambled with our
brackets and then we all cursed J billis
when Arizona bowed out